e marguerite yourcenar pour mishima ou
la vision du vide paru chez gallimard il
ya quelques jours et jean d'ormesson
pour dieu sa vie son oeuvre paru
également chez gallimard
alors je vais évidemment on devrait
parler de dieu d'abord mishima ensuite
par ordre chronologique ou par ordre de
préséance
mais enfin je pense que dieu n'est pas
une mine un peu de fantaisie n'allons
donc pas vous commencez par mishima
mais c'est tout de même à vous je vais
poser la première question genre me sens
selon vous qui connaissez bien le mari
tueur sonar qu'est ce qui l'a déterminé
à écrire un livre sur ce grand écrivain
japonais mishima
je ne voulais pas répondre à la place de
marguerite yourcenar si vous la
connaissez bien il yad'abord ya d'abord
quelque chose de fantastique dans dans
dans la vie mishima c'est sa mort alors
évidemment surtout pour quelqu'un qui
comme marguerite yourcenar est comme moi
je crois pensons que ce qui compte dans
un écrivain c'est d'abord son oeuvre et
non pas sa vie il ya là un exemple de
quelqu'un ou la mort prend une telle
importance qu on ne peut pas parler de
son oeuvre
sans parler de sa mort c'est à dire de
sa vie
ça ça me paraît quelque chose qui est
extraordinairement fort on ne pourra
évidemment plus jamais évoquer les
livres de mishima
sans parler de cette fatigue est-ce que
la réponse vous satisfait mais à peu
près même un peu plus loin et je dirais
que la mort de mishima est une de ses
oeuvres est la plus soigneusement
préparé de ses heures autrement dit si
ni schéma au lieu de de se donner la
mort et on verra tout à l'heure comme en
a 45 ans était mort d'un cancer ou mort
d'un accident de voiture vous n'auriez
problement pas écrit un livre sur lui
peut-être j'aurais apprécié certaines
séries devraient être prévues en lui un
exemple très intéressant d'un japonais
européaniser et retournant un peu à la
fois à la pensée ancestrale mais enfin
j'aurais sans doute je ne laisserai
alors parlons tout de suite de la mort
de mishima qui est sa dernière oeuvre
c'est une mort qu'il a claqué lille
pense depuis plusieurs années au moins
six ans oui on peut suivre dans les
livres écrits dans les six dernières
années
cette obsession de 7 meur dont on peut
dire qu'il fait plusieurs répétitions
il ya aussi un film c'est ça il joue
même sept mois
initialement des remarquables alors il
se donne la mort le 25 novembre 1970
mais d'abord ce jour-là une termine une
oeuvre
c'est cela lance ce que je vais
présenter dans mon livre comme l'ange
pourri et qui paraîtra le titre dans la
traduction par gallimard sera l'ange en
décomposition si je faisais le livre est
paru
alors il a mis donc le point final on ne
sait pas si l'acquis la dernière phrase
ou s'il a vraiment corriger amplement
corriger quelques virgules les a en tout
cas il avait promis à son éditeur le
manuscrit définitif c'est cela et il l'a
envoyé à l'éditeur vers 9 heures du
matin le jour de sa mort et que fait-il
après et que fait-elle après il
s'habille soigneusement dans l'uniforme
de cette espèce de société deux à la
fois société de gymnastique société
secrète requis pour lui représentait une
espèce de protestation contre les
traités qui limitait les armements du
japon est en fait qu il limiter la
liberté japonaise et qui comportait tout
au plus 100 tonnes
c'était beaucoup plus symbolique
symbolique que pratique elle ne voudrait
pas étendre davantage disait-il
cette société il s'agit donc de cet
uniforme rejoint quelques amis qui
appartenaient au même groupe et alors
par des moyens en somme terroristes qui
nous gênait un peu maintenant surtout
que depuis dix ans nous avons vu de
nombreux exemples de terrorisme plus
grave encore seront chez le commandant
de la place de tokyo en général en
général pour lui montrer pour une
prétendait rambur ans est visé pour lui
montrer un sabre du xviie siècle qu'il
possédait dont il était très fier et
pour faire admirer au général magnifique
6 ur du sabre et prend note générale se
pencher sur le sabre il est saisi par
les trois acolytes demi fumât on faire
mal de l'intérieur les portes à clé et
le général est ligoté à son siège
et on lui demande de par téléphone
d'ordonner qu'on réunisse la troupe
enfin les troupes disponibles dans la
cour pour que mégi mappus le faire
devant les troupes sa protestation final
on parlemente pendant quelques temps on
finit par accepter cette demande de
crainte du pire et on réunit les troupes
qui bien entendu s'élevait à environ
seulement 800 900 hommes qui se sont
réunis salle enthousiasme ne comprenant
pas très bien pourquoi cette corvée
d'autre part prudemment les comment
dirais-je le bureau du général fait
prévenir je ne sais quel ministère et on
envoie un hélicoptère qui passe et
repasse au-dessus de la cour où doit
avoir lieu ce dernier discours de
protestation mishima qui était un
athlète très remarquable saute sur le
rebord du balcon comment sa protestation
japonais vous ne vous rendez pas compte
que notre pays enfin perdu son honneur
et qu'il est temps de sortir de ce
marasme et de rentrer dans des principes
enfin qu un peu plus nos robes l'est un
peu moins soumises aux directives de la
nation étrangère en train je sais que
tout ça de mémoire d'avril à peu près ce
qu'il a voulu dire
et naturellement personne de l'entente
il rit même wii se moque de lui tout le
monde se moque de nuit on sait pas trop
ce qui se passe l'hélicoptère bourdonne
au dessus de la cour mishima redescendu
au bord de la balustrade rentrer dans le
bureau du général fermée à clé comme on
vient d'indiquer s'assied à un mètre du
général et accomplissons c'est plus
c'est plus le mot noble le mot chinois
qui signifie la mise à mort par
éventuellement est en fait quoi que ce
serait important siens mais dans
beaucoup de cas la personne qu'ils
accomplissaient généralement par
protestation ou comme une forme de
suicide un peu
oser parler ou l'autorité de ces
années-là n'arrivait pas à se tuer il
n'arrivait qu'à souffrir beaucoup et ça
s'applique et une blessure très
douloureuse mais il est entendu dans
nombre de cas qu'il serait qu'il
recevrait le coup de grâce d'un acolyte
et c'est ce qu'on avait à ranger dans le
cadre des films à un de ses lieutenants
devait lui trancher la tête
immédiatement
enfin seulement lusage il s'appelle
morita c'est plus qu'un lieutenant il
s'appelait morita c'est aussi le dernier
raid est la dernière personne n'ayant
pas entrer dans ce groupe est un ami
intime de certains m'ont même dit que
c'était son amant ça n'en savons rien
seul n'en savons rien alors donc
d'ailleurs on voit un document où l'on
voit les deux têtes tranchées parce
qu'ensuite lamy qui lui a coupé la tête
se fait aussi couper la tête par un
autre et on voit sur l'extrême gauche
les les deux têtes
les deux têtes qui vient d'être coupé
évidemment les ce moment là les milliers
ils interviennent et comme je l'aï
indiqué d'ailleurs dans le livre il ya
là c'est toute cette chose selon si
émouvante dans patriotique dans le film
de mishima ne sait plus pu se dérouler
avec une dignité une perfection
imperturbable dans la réalité ça ne
s'est pas passé tout à fait de la même
façon le l'acolyte enfin morita a été
saisie de deux douleurs et d'angoissant
voyant mourir son chef
ça m'a beaucoup tremblé il n'a pas
réussi à décapiter il a fallu que ce
soit quelqu'un d'autre qui le fasse et
lui même a été immédiatement
immédiatement reçu le coup de grâce
aussi d'un second acolytes
voilà donc il ya eu un désarroi qui dans
quillan l'art au contraire ne s'est pas
produit il se produit pas dans le film
jean d'ormesson commandes quelle
explication de cette mort parce qu'il
faut bien dire que mishima et un
écrivain très connu qui a obtenu
beaucoup de succès qui est riche et qui
a le carrefour recueilli tous les
honneurs et puis tout d'un coup à 45 ans
issu prix justement ce qui m'intéresse
c'est de savoir c est ce que mishima qui
représente une tendance d'extrême droite
ne sait pas de quoi il est leader
japonais peut-être un peu différent de
notre ex très probablement
soit mais est ce que c'est pour ses
opinions politiques qu'il s'est suicidé
ou est ce que il était travail et d'un
besoin de suicide et qu'il a choisi ce
cheval de ce cheval suicidaire comme il
en aurait choisi un autre est ce que
vous croyez que c'est vraiment pour les
motifs politiques qui s'est suicidé ou
qu'il était décidé à se suicider et
qu'il a choisi la voie politique je
crois qu'on ne peut jamais répondre
simplement une question de cet ordre que
les motifs d'un être humain
son centre croise toujours et plus
l'homme est intelligent plus leurs mets
raffinés plus il y a un nombre
considérable de motifs quelquefois même
contradictoires certainement oui film a
été hanté toute sa vie par l'idée de la
mort heures en tant que japonais il a
toujours était plat d'une profonde
admiration pour les road sera ce qui
s'était suicidé de cette manière là
d'autre part il l'a raconté lui même
très franchement que dans sa jeunesse
par exemple lorsque jeunes étudiants et
les raies dans les rues de tokyo
incendié par les bombes
il n'était pas particulièrement sensible
à la défaite du japon se préoccuper de
sa propre carrière de la mort de sa
jeune soeur qui venait de mourir du fiep
typhoïde et c est que la politique ne
l'intéressait pas à ce moment là
beaucoup
il avait même été enchantés d'avoir
refusé à l'armée comme - comme conscrits
parce que il souffrait légèrement d'une
tuberculose d'un commencement
tuberculose
d'autre part 20 ans était passé ses
souvenirs s'était mise en place il avait
été hanté par la l'image de la défaite
japonaise et surtout par l'image du trop
facile réalignement des affaires sont
les affaires qui avaient immédiatement
suivi on s'en aperçoit très bien dans
son oeuvre
il avait décrit d'une façon hallucinante
toxo tokyo incendiés dans laquelle il
est vrai centre au pirée fléchir
lorsqu'il avait 20 ans et 20 ans plus
tard il avait montré une façon admirable
dans un de ses romans ses espaces
complètement désert iront reconnaissable
et une vieille femme assise sur un banc
tâchant de retrouver l'endroit où elle
avait vécu donc entre temps une
comment dirais-je une évolution s'était
fait en lui
de plus il était extrêmement sensible à
ce monde du succès à ce monde eu la vie
facile de la dolce vita qui l'avait
d'ailleurs à laquelle il avait participé
lui-même mais il s'en était sans doute
lassé en tout cas ils envoyaient les
mauvais aspects et dans plusieurs poèmes
qui précède de peu sa mort il se plaint
que la vie ait perdu son goût et son sel
est alors en fait de toutes ces deux
désespoir de cette assurance fait à ses
amis que le japon ne s'en sortirait pas
qu'il entrait dans une période
descendante est sorti évidemment peu un
peu à peu un un peu à la fois cette
décision de mourir alors là dessus on a
raconté toutes sortes de choses on a
parlé d'exhibitionnisme
on a parlé du fait qu'ils n'avaient pas
eu prix nobel l'année précédente
ça me paraît pas excessif quand il ya
action oui mais il ya quand même d'une
autre une autre version que d'une chose
à votre avis là-dessus jean d'ormesson
beaucoup ont dit aussi que et là c'est
la lecture de la mer de fertilité qui
nous encourage un petit lieu à ces lions
là savoir que à 45 ans il a eu peur de
la vieillesse il a eu peur de l'échec
final ils allaient qu'il a voulu contrer
contrairement à ce que ne fait pas on da
c'est le héros de l'amer 6 fertilité il
a voulu mourir en pleine possession de
ses moyens
hélas toujours cru que c'était là la
mort enfin la plus souhaitable
voilà plutôt que d'attendre une sorte de
dégradation physique intellectuelle non
je ne crois pas que les montées cette
immense et compliqué mise en scène de
suicide avec protestation aux troupes
banderole déployée etc
précédé par pas mal d'action politique
comme par exemple son grand débat avec
les étudiants communistes de tokyo dans
lequel il reconnaissait que jusqu'à un
certain point il leur appartenait tout
en étant leur adversaire puisque tous
deux avaient le goût de l'action pousser
jusqu'à l'extrême limite mais je vous
comprends qu'il aurait fait tout ça
simplement pour ceux pour s'offrir une
porte de sortie
on peut rêver comme qu'est ce qui se
serait passé si les troupes au lieu de
riz est se moquer l'avait suivi parce
qu'ils en auraient été heureux
ou est ce qu'il à l'arrêt était
désespérée corps effet napoléon s'il a
bien su vaincre à le faire leurs biens
ça nous n'en savons il a faim il est
probable que mishima ce serait quand
même suicidé même dans le succès vous le
croyez peut-être un peu plus tard le
succès mais pas loin
je ressens bien compte que rien ne
pouvait mener loin à ce moment là que
cette protestation même si elle habite
et suivi d'un certain sucré n'aurait
tout de même pas changer les choses est
particulièrement changer les traités
contre lesquels mes schémas
professionnels en fait c'est un homme
tout à fait curieux et vous parlez très
souvent des des photographies il s'est
souvent laissé photographier et dans des
situations un petit peu extravagante par
exemple et vous en parlez dans votre
vivent de cette photographie où il est
représenté en saint-sébastien perd ses
deux flèches tout à fait extravagance a
quand même non non parce qu'après t il y
avait en mai chez mad l'acteur il avait
très souvent joué sur la scène
il avait d'abord joué et admirablement
le principal rôle dans le film
patriotisme
il avait lancé sébastien il avait payé
un goût passionné pour racine qui ne
peut que nous toucher il avait joué un
gros deux comparses dans britannicus
traduit en japonais par lui ou pas rome
une traduction révisée par ses soins il
avait joué dans certaines pièces de
kabuki il y avait donc en lui de
l'acteur le point de son extérieur
d'objets en acteur d'autre part il a qu
il a publié tout ou plutôt on a publié
juste après sa mort tout un album qu'il
représente mourant de diverses mort plus
ou moins symbolique et tout fait dans la
boue écrasé par un camion on peut voir
là assez facilement certains symboles
uimm qui crève les yeux on ça sébastien
se suicidant en commettant c'est plus
comme il l'a fait lui-même et il y à là
est certainement une obsession de la
mort
or pour nos contemporains les options de
la mort paraissent toujours un peu
malsaine un peu insensé pourquoi donc
penser à tout ça mais là nous sommes
nouveaux
nous sommes des novateurs comparer non
seulement au japon et à l'extrême
au contraire on a toujours beaucoup
pensé à la main mais même à nos propres
ancêtres nos arrière-grands-parents
penser à leurs fins dernières il pensait
même chaque soir dans leur examen de
conscience est considéré en fait se
demander souvent quand même le faisait
madame de sévigné
comment pourrais-je serais-je tuée dans
un accident de voiture
mon rêve d'une fièvre de stress est ce
que ce sera subitement ou lentement
enfin et c est ce genre de réflexion est
excessivement courant dans la
littérature chrétienne
jusqu'au xviiie siècle jean d'ormesson
je vous avais lu les romans dits chemin
qu'est ce que fera quand même parlé
aussi un peu de pas seulement de sa vie
mais aussi par les deux de ses romans
pourquoi selon vous c'est un grand
écrivain il faut dire d'abord qu'il a
publié beaucoup d'heures premier publié
près d'une quarantaine mais qu'elle a
beaucoup qui sont des ouvrages un petit
peu je dirais de commerciaux de moi j'ai
littérature et les cadeaux l'alimentaire
mais enfin il a écrit une dizaine qui
sont des grands livres je pense qu'il ya
quelque chose qu'il faut dire aussi
c'est que ce fanatique japonais cet
ardent défenseur du retour à la
puissance de l'empereur a été très
influencé par l'occident et étaient au
moins très curieux l'occident très
influencé par la france
c'est ça la france il parle de crest
brasse et lui parle de racine
passionnément il parle de balzac
il avait aussi une culture anglaise
assez importante
pas du tout américaine c'est assez
frappant parce que le japon depuis et
même à l'époque où il souffrait enfin
des changements qui s'était produit dans
la civilisation japonaise était et est
encore fortement américanisé mishima
n'était pas américanisé il était
anglicisé offensives et il ya quelque
chose d'assez frappant c'est que ces
influences mais là des choses qui elles
nous sont difficilement compréhensibles
par exemple le thème de la transpiration
des armes qui joua un grand rôle dans le
dans sa tétralogie dans la mer doivent
surtout net à la mer la fertilité dont
le dernier volume
nous avons quatre nuls qui sont parus
qui viennent de paraître alors là un
lecteur européen est peut-être un peu
décontenancé oui par le rôle de ceux de
ce passage des armes il l'est sans doute
mais pas peut-être pas plus qu'un
lecteur orientale serait comment
dirais-je tout d'un coup surpris par la
notion du jugement dernier enfin il
s'agit là de dom on sait ce taux qui de
part et d'autre sont acceptées même par
les gens qui n'y croient pas comme enfin
un concept qu'on accepte facilement
maintenant il faut bien dire est une
chose assez curieuse dans la question de
la religion des religions si on peut
dire car après tout le japon à deux
religions demi-finale il ya le shintô
qui est le culte impérial culte des
ancêtres
le cumul des lieux sacrés de la terre
mishima toujours eu un certain intérêt
et même un très grand intérêt pour ce
que tu es et jusqu'à un certain point
certainement il ya certaines ses plus
belles descriptions s'y rapportent
comme par exemple celle des suicides des
samouraïs qui assiste à des rites à des
cérémonies film tôt avant de se tuer au
moment où commencent et
l'européanisation du japon vers le début
du siècle
d'autre part le bouddhisme qui est aussi
une part profond de l'âme japonaise
semble avoir beaucoup moins intéressé et
on a par moment l'impression qu'il s'est
informée du bouddhisme presque à coups
de manuels les écoutes dictionnaire pour
revenir un peu à cette pensée
d'autrefois qui pour lui était une
pensée d'autrefois moi je la crois
encore très vivante mais un peu comme un
jeu du français qui n'auraient pas été
élevé dans le catholicisme et qui tout
d'un coup c'est intéresserait vous
soumettrai que d'un coup à lire les
théologiens et dont le
dans l'avenant la tétralogie de la
fertilité
il est certain que cela sa présentation
de la transmigration est plus populaire
que sa vente
c'est à dire que ceux de légendes
populaires des superstitions populaires
comme par exemple très souvent des
personnes se réincarne ont
successivement meurent plus ou moins au
même âge ce qui n'est défendue à aucune
théorie théologique que je sache et car
la théologie bouder quand il s'agit de
la transmigration et si
extraordinairement compliquée 6 avant
qu'elle est excessivement difficile à
définir mais en amour on peut se référer
à une grande phrase qui est d'origine
hindoue east le seigneur seul transmig
c'est à dire les éléments les plus
élevés de notre personnalité ne meurt
pas ce qui ne veut pas du tout dire que
notre individualité demeure et surtout
pour les bouddhistes ne crois pas du
tout à l'individualité pour qu'il
n'existe pas pour qui l'homme comme pour
marcel proust n'est que le lieu d'un
passage d'émotions et de sensations qui
sans cesse se détruisent l'une l'autre
on ne voit pas très bien ce qu'ils
transmig regret donc il ya là un vieux
et j'ai mishima entre la position
théologique véritable et la position
populaire fait ce qu on dit couramment
dans la conversation
mais dans la mer de furtivité il ya
plusieurs personnages qui ont trois
grains de beauté toujours la mainmise à
ça c'est une nouvelle super six et que
ça veut dire que ce sont des élus on se
fabrique ce sont des gens qui suivent en
quelque sorte la même ligne et aux
migrations
on retrouve des thèmes de ce genre par
exemple de la cagouille qu'en racontant
des légendes japonaises de la fin du 19e
siècle et ceux qui ce qui me frappe
du point de vue purement esthétique du
point de vue romanesque c'est que ça a
permis à nisima d'offrir du japon de
boillon de 1912 1932 1954 et 1970 quatre
images qui au lieu d'être comme dans la
plupart de nos romans européen et quand
il s'agit d'écrire une série de
génération on prend le père l'arrière
grand-père le père
le grand-père le père et le fils est au
rsa l'intérieur d'une famille comme par
exemple thomas cependant les buddenbrook
ou kong alberti que nous lisons
maintenant - ou comme tout le monde ou
j'oserais même dire comme moi dans vos
archives du nord souvenirs pieux qui ne
sont pas là lire des romans tandis qu'en
cas de mishima là l'idée de représenter
des personnages transmis grand lui a
permis de prendre chaque fois des
personnels de type différent si tu es
des niveaux sociaux ou dans des milieux
différents mais ça ça sans mérite
mais est ce que vous considérez gens ne
sont que la mère de fertilité c'est le
testament
évidemment on se dit puisqu'il détermine
ce livre le jour même où il se donne la
mres lice son testament mais ce que
vraiment si son testament pour vous ça
sur questions vraiment difficiles vous
savez que je crois qu'il est ce au
moment de mourir je crois qu'il écrit
une phrase oui à balhaf art qui est une
phrase admirable d'ailleurs et qui est
qui est une phrase sur la vie autant que
sont la mort je me rappelle pas
exactement les termes de leur race et
les îles à la vie la vie humaine est
brève mais je voudrais vivre toujours
vouvoyé et et c'est ça c'est très
curieux aussi comment l'interprétez-vous
sacha trouve assez simple je comprends
et à ya ce grand amour de la vie j'ai
presque tous les créateurs je crois que
tous les grands créateurs romanesque
comme par exemple balzac ont
passionnément aimée l'avait seulement
dans quelles conditions les schémas
souffre évidemment peut-être de
certaines préoccupations et trouble
personnel que nous ne connaissons pas
vous pourrez pas par nous et qu'on n'a
pas jugé que ne sont pas évoqués d'autre
part il souffrait certainement comme
helmand de la situation de son pays
et évidemment la vie humaine est brève
et je voudrais vivre toujours à
condition que les conditions soient
tolérable et que ne soit pas non plus si
l'on peut dire déshonneur et vous dites
vous même qu'il a écrit un livre heureux
et vous dites vous même que c'est un
sorte de chefs-d'oeuvre c'est le tumulte
des flots c'est ça et est à dire
beaucoup plus jeune oui il avait qui l'a
jeudi écrit sable trentaine d'années
cette manière
pauline et en 25 35 il devait avoir
environ 28 en même temps je suis pas sûr
c'est un livre d'amour est un ravissant
une ravissante histoire qui ressemble
adapté c'est chloé et qui à mon avis
même a le mérite d'être infiniment plus
réaliste se passant dans un milieu très
pauvre permis des pêcheurs d'une petite
île et évoquant un amour sans complexe
mais avec toutes les difficultés de la
pauvreté de la séparation des deux
amoureux ça beaucoup de grâce et il ya
quelques scènes inoubliables qui
commence déjà d'ailleurs l'obsession du
sera la sienne de la différence entre
une société de consommation entre un
monde de luxe et le monde de la pauvreté
qui tout de même lui sous jacques sous
jacents et on verra voeux de façon très
forte dans la dans la tétralogie ce
thème dans chevaux échappés ou i know
lutte contre les maux des rêves les
grands trusts les grandes sociétés
affairistes et bien des gens dans un
point d'un très court et très émouvant
symbole dans ce livre heureux dont je
parle et à la scène lille qui sont des
des pêcheuses de perles qu'elle se soit
des pêcheuses d'abalo n'est plus
exactement sorte de la mer glacée
haletante et caetera et se couche
d'humus autour d'un feu pour se
réchauffer un tout petit peu et à ce
moment là parce le colporteur venus de
la ville apportant des petits sacs en
plastique qui coûte très cher et les
pauvres femmes qui ne s'épuise et meurt
à la tâche regardent avec convoitise les
petits sacs en plastique peu plus ce qui
devrait coûter tout au plus un dollar
mais c'est un peu plus cher et qui est
qui et qui décide de les acheter enfin
sont prises par ce faux luxe qu'ils
auraient à faire du dehors
c'est tout chaud mais c'est triste à
dire un mot aussi d'un beau livre qui le
pavillon d'or tribaux vous dites une
manière de shader qui est un très beau
une manière de chanel quoi le pavillon
dos
le pavillon d'or c'est une histoire de
dingue
d'un novice qui qui même façon tant
qu'ils adorent qui est qui et qui adore
son temple et qui met le feu
ce qui est quand même aussi une image la
vie de mishima mais oui et c'est aussi
très curieusement quelque chose qu'on
pourrait transposer en termes
occidentaux car c'était encore l'époque
où mishima écrivait des romans un peu un
peu comme le roman occident même tout à
fait comme roman occidentaux et alors ce
jeune séminariste carré les séminaristes
bouddhiste qui à la fois adore le temple
si les tees et d'un séminariste
catholique je dirais adore l'église d'un
hacker qui laquelle il a l'occasion
d'aller et de venir tous les jours et
qui en même temps se trouve très irrité
par les les enseignements qui lui
semblent routinier et un peu poussiéreux
qu'on lui donne on voit on va très bien
un écrivain même à bernanos
nous représentons un séminariste
catholique pris entre la fois le
mécontentement le découragement le
désespoir devant une religion qui lui
donne plus autant qu'il pourrait
l'espérer et son amour passionné pour
certaines structures certains souvenirs
du bon passé religieux qu'elle
représente bien sûr que le désespoir et
la mort remarque d'amour moi il ya une
chose que je tout à fait fascinant c'est
le suicide d'un autre écrivain japonais
c'est de l'écrivain kawabata qu il eut
obtenu le prix nobel de littérature qui
se suicident à raison à l'occidentale
alors qu'ils suivent un an c'est parce
qu'on accidentally suis un an après
mishima
il faut dire que s'il a été le maître de
mishima même et lui sont surveillés
alors il s'est passé mais l'occidentale
je dirais il se suicide comme les
pauvres gens c'est à dire il ouvre le
gaz simplement
alors je dis est ce que conduit à une à
bell oui mais vous il vous fallait donc
que cet argument n'était pas décisif
mais bon mais est ce que je n'arrive pas
je suis bon kawabata pourquoi ce sui
team au gaz est ce qu'il n'ya pas il ne
donne pas une leçon un an après la mort
de michel foucault pas du tout parce
qu'il avait il était resté jusqu'au bout
lundi dmitri mal la photographie qu'il
montre assistant à l'enterrement est
évidemment désolé et extrêmement
émouvante et de plus il avait raconté
par été plusieurs fois
avoir vu l'apparition de mishima durant
la dernière la dernière année enfin
l'année qui sépare la mort de mishima de
sa propre mort je crois qu'il s'est
suicidé
deux nouveaux ne connaissons pas les
raisons secrètes comme mishima comme
cave à bata n'était pas un écrivain
d'éthique politique pour autant que je
sache ne savons pas non plus quelle est
son point de vue vis-à-vis des affaires
du monde il s'est suicidé parce qu'il en
avait assez tout simplement équivaut
visage est aussi et était beaucoup plus
âgée et comme comme son arc est un tout
en nuances tout en finesse je crois
qu'il est mort le plus discrètement
possible l'écart web et a fait ce que
honda ne fait pas la mère de fertilité
c'est d'ailleurs vous voudriez commandes
à ces suicides il a le regret et un
certain moment vers la fin ici comme une
voie qui est en pleine déliquescence à
la famille intellectuelle
il a le regret un peu de jeu ne suis pas
tout à fait bondir je crois qu'on
m'honore mais il m'a vue nous montrer un
roda passant par la déliquescence la
vieillesse la série télé est
certainement certains certains drames de
sa vie privée comme comme un sur des
scandales de moeurs qui se produit et
devant tout au mieux toutes ces misères
honda tout d'un tout de même avance un
peu à la fois
il commence à réfléchir un peu plus
profondément à sa vie il comme et
certaines erreurs graves comme par
exemple ils adoptent quelqu'un qui ne
méritait pas d'être adopté et en souffre
beaucoup
mais finalement il se décider alors
c'est là tout de même un des moments
héroïques du livre il se décide à
remonter la colline du monastère où se
trouve la jeune femme qui avait été
l'ami et l'amante de son ami de son
camarade fallait d'autrefois et il avait
de la pure vu depuis 50 ans mais il se
dit que peut-être enfin avant de mourir
ces deux personnes âgées pourront
ensemble discuter du sens de la vie et
de leurs veillées d'autrefois et il te
retrouves la baisse enfoncé comme
pourrait de nouveau être une abaisse de
chez nous dans la prière dans la
méditation et refusant de reparler de ce
qui a été sa vie passionnel et sa vie
sociale d'autrefois et lui ont d'art
péniblement ayant fait ce chemin pour
arriver jusqu'à m
un moment tout de même presque
d'affolement habilement fait il tout ça
ne compte pas c'est rien de tout ça n'a
vraiment existé à leur mois honda ou en
suis-je
est ce que fait exister et l'avait ce
midi c'est à chacun nous d'en décider
selon son coeur monsieur honda et à ce
moment là elle le pont dans un jardin
hivernale du monastère est très beau ça
un beau jour d'été et on pourrait dire
parce que pour la première fois de sa
vie honda qui est un homme et ses poses
haïk assez quelconque s'aperçoit que le
ciel est très bleu et que c'est tout de
même très beau c'est à dire qu'il est
arrivé à une sorte d'élan d'idéalisme
avant de mourir ça vaut peut-être la
peine d'aller jusqu'aux gâtisme pour en
arriver là encore un dernier mot sur le
temple de l'aube en face au tout la
mairie festivités qui est traduit de
l'anglais est à noter par tanguy qui
n'est tenu très bien mais alors est-ce
qu'on peut ne pas regretter que
finalement la traduction ne se fasse pas
directement du japonais qu'elle soit
obligée de passer par parle anglais
jean d'ormesson vous vous kétamine
escola c'est un problème évidemment
comment ne le regretterai ton pas
comment notamment la grée traitons pas
le principe de la double traduction est
un principe je m'appelle que taiwan en
parlait souvent le principe de la double
traduction est un principe appendicite
aspect très dans vôtre vous imaginez les
glissements qui se font moi j'imagine
danseurs normes sont traduits en anglais
puis re traduit en japonais
bon bah ça doit peut-être d'avoir des
glissements quand même le sens dans tout
ça non mais écoutez on peut prendre
l'exemple puisse enfin je parle sous
votre contrôle madame le dernier titre
lange en décomposition le dernier le
quatrième de la mer de fer trième de la
mer de fertilité lange en décomposition
c'est une idée qui a déjà beaucoup plus
fort c'est déjà plus fort et en japonais
c'est une formule qui se réfère à toute
une mythologie des anges qui qui sont
pas tout à fait une mortelle et qui
dépliés il ya il ya cette plaie qui se
forme sur eux ils auront leur sofa fleur
se fane chapelle mais dans leurs dents
semble bien que l'ange en décomposition
c'est une formule un peu stéréotypé qui
veut dire il n'y a pas de bonnes choses
qui ne finissent même les plus belles
roses finissent par fans et alors vous
voyez c'est quelque chose qui à
l'oreille japonaise sonne de façon
beaucoup plus familière que l'ange en
décomposition viande pourrie mari
toujours ce nas ou penser que dieu est
un bon sujet de roman parce que là on
abandonne l'aca cette petite créature
que mishima ps et on venir maintenant a
dû revenir à dieu et aux créatures ce
qu'elle dieu va poser les vieux qui
seront surtout je crois
chateaubriand et madame récamier voilà
bon alors changeons de sujet et pensons
à dieu voilà c'est bien je ne sais pas
du tout si dieu est un bon sujet droit
membres croient que dieu est présent
dans tous les romans puisque après tout
on peut dire que c'est dieu ou bien qui
ordonne le monde bien qu'il rêve ou que
nous pouvons nous référer à lui enfin
dans tout ce qui nous arrive
genre